this is amazing just for the creeps and
listeners out there Danny has called no
less than four times trying to figure
out how to get here now there is an
address he's coming we've been told he's
coming we are a place now we're up an
address here and we are at a place in
time
where we have phones that have a map on
now generally speaking I'd say that did
he drive himself question well I'm gonna
bet you that may being the A Plus
student she is she got very specific
with the directions of where to park how
to enter into the alley Where and then
and then where and what door to walk
through but what building
yeah is that correct uh yeah I I gave a
satellite photo with a big red circle
around where the parking lot was
um that's amazing I tried hey you know
but you know what it's easy
he's an 80 year old icon
you can lead a horse to water
you could lead an icon to a podcast
Studio
but you can't make them show up you
can't make him walk through the door
oh wait I hear a voice I hear a voice I
hear a voice I grew up it's like Santa
coming isn't it
found it
oh God how are you
come have a seat yes in the hot seat in
the hot seat baby so good to see you
ladies and gentlemen daddy DeVito guys
oh my God Global Superstar is late
because he went to some people's house
that was really good here's the question
did you drive yourself or did somebody
drive I drove myself and I used the
thing and I and I uh we're missing a
North or a south or something or an East
or West was is that is that I have to
pee by the way
by the way P anyway it was like around
the block but it was really good you
know very big fans and I took some
selfies and we had a good time but I
didn't know I saw I swear to God I said
when I called you I said you punked me
he was texting me very funny because of
course I thought it was a joke yeah yeah
and it was nobody it was like a
residential neighborhood it's really
cool yeah and the people were very nice
and they had a Christmas tree up not as
elaborate as you guys and you just
knocked on the ones I rang their little
security Bell they came to the door it
was a newlywed couple and they were very
happy to see me
dude
then I started to backtrack I didn't
want to say like too much because I
thought I thought it was like you guys
were busting my balls yeah yeah I said
like it wouldn't be the first time that
would have been good no it would have
been really good balls you need to go to
the bathroom uh that's my bladder I
don't know where the pee comes from it
doesn't come from this isn't a biology
podcast well it could it could dribble
onto the balls I don't know how well
some of the balls it's going to get
really uncomfortable yeah yeah I better
go yeah yeah I'm gonna drain the monster
drain the monster baby I'll be right
back
[Music]
hey everybody
wow this is a big day and this is big
Monumental I'm gonna put my sweater on
yeah
thank you you know this is so good while
you go while you're putting on that
sweater I would like to pose a question
to all of you but mostly you because
I've heard plenty from them and I don't
really want to hear anymore I've had
enough of them how do you feel about
Christmas music yeah starting to play
before December
I don't listen or before sorry before
Thanksgiving I don't listen to the I
don't go anywhere where it's like I
don't go to an elevator
yeah nobody in my house plays it okay oh
really yeah I mean you know but I don't
I don't dislike it but I don't I think
it's stupid and Christmas is like really
like basically just to sell things right
because that's what happened like it in
the economy like years ago around that
time sales were dipping so somebody said
well we got to do something to fix this
so let's do some holiday yeah so they
picked uh they co-opted the winter
solstice or whatever it's called well
you know and they well this is his
birthday wasn't born that day yeah yeah
no no no no no no Hey listen what I
wasn't there uh I shouldn't say that
they was I shouldn't tell well you know
the idea hold on well they were already
scientifically research this they
followed the star in Bethlehem at that
time of the year that starred in existed
existed at a different time so he was
actually born I think in March or a yeah
that the Bible's not true
well Danny he's ruined Christmas you've
read you've ruined Jesus and uh I I
chickened out of doing the the meats the
what do you call it the 23andMe thing I
went I sent in the thing and then they
sent me the kit and then I said [ __ ] you
know like what am I going to do with it
you know like get because I figure like
I got like a lot of my family's from
Calabria and from uh so I think down one
of my grandparents is from like Calabria
which is right at the boot of of Italy
and right there is Albania and and she
spoke I only knew her like when I was
like a really little kid she was like
already 80 something and dying like of
something laying in a bed she broke her
hip
tragic story sorry to bring it up great
Christmas story but the idea is that she
spoke a language called gig
and now people out there may know what
that is some people may know what it is
it's a kind of an Albanian kind of
hybrid language that was in Italian
Albanian thing my grandfather of course
didn't like it because she spoke with
her girlfriends and that was the story
Anyway
come in the room he's picking a gag and
in the language it's like I I met one
person
on my travels who actually knew the
language and also a guy was born down in
the real where the southern tip of Italy
and and the language is really beautiful
like like for rain the only word I know
is
and it's all these soft kind of weird
really beautiful sounds nothing like you
would think like a a hard Italian or an
Arabic sound it was all like uh
beautiful uh almost like music each
other
they didn't get the end yeah
it's raining shut the [ __ ] up and get
out of the rain yeah
that was a I didn't do the thing because
no somebody shushed you well I was
worried that like you get the DNA out
there and then you know how it is in the
world everybody knows all the [ __ ] about
that you know huh there you know well
who's they they're computer people those
guys the people they know those guys the
Deep State
they know where you're from they know
all about you buddy they know more than
you know about yourself so when are we
going back to work by the way uh we
start shooting at the end of January
we've got got a lot of fun episodes that
we've been talking about oh man that's
exciting don't tell me the spoilers here
no spoilers okay should we should we
visit the ghosts of Christmas Past and
should we discuss uh either your
Beginnings in the career should we go
that far back or should we just go Sunny
everybody knows they can look it up
talk about the beginning of Sunny yeah
I'll tell you story about Sonics do you
have a structure
some questions but it was going to be
good commenting you how you got involved
with Sonny okay well I okay I'll tell
you how I got involved years and years
ago at Jersey I worked with John
landgraff because he was at NBC and I
needed somebody to run my television
department and we
he came to work with me at Jersey films
okay that was years and years ago then
that all broke up and then he got this
gig with um you know FX
he called me one day he said I I just
did this show Eight Episodes of some
really crazy show that I you know I'm
like I don't know you know tell me what
you what's your opinion so he sent me
the the Eight Episodes and Maria and I
and the kids watched the show I loved it
it was [ __ ] outrageous just the way
they are okay and we all you know I
immediately said yeah this is like a
amazing show you should whatever you're
gonna do with it I don't know and then I
hear from anybody right you know like
and you know I don't talk to him all the
time all of a sudden he calls me up he
says would you be interested in in being
on the show
and I said yeah I said if they come up
with
um organic character something that was
not just Danny DeVito coming into a show
if it was if it made sense
blah blah blah all that kind of stuff
and it was a good character and so they
wrote me in and of course
my two kids are tall and blonde and so I
had to have eventually as we all know my
wife was a [ __ ] and so you know so that
so that was my first involvement why
this show
everybody else be that yeah every single
person that I knew asked me that the
doorman asked me that anybody you know
why are you gonna do that you were like
a TV icon you were in one of the most
popular shows in the world taxi you were
always blah blah blah blah why do this
show and I felt like it's it's why do
you do anything it's a gut feeling you
you you feel comfortable then I had that
meeting with you guys where we sat and
talked about it you know where I was
probably drunk sorry
hey man
oh no Valentina oh I'm not gonna needle
I'm come hanging up on you I'm not
getting this shot okay goodbye I gotta
go Danny I often think about
you having the foresight to
because I think it's really easy to
start to get some success to get really
careful and protective of that success
just the guts to say I think I'm gonna
jump into this thing
and to be able to see it and see the
potential in it I think you know you
often read about like I was just reading
an article and I was talking about how
much Burt Reynolds hated doing Boogie
Nights and was just dragging PTA the
whole time and like you know I think
there's a point in your career you're
like what am I doing I'm doing a movie
about the porn industry or like what am
I doing I'm running around in Philly and
they're shooting in these crappy little
cameras but uh it's I think you have
that uh and always have had that ability
to just kind of see what could work
I was gonna say were you thinking that
far ahead or were you just like oh yeah
no I was thinking I was thinking
immediate I always think like right now
what's going on right now so like I did
say what I said to to land graph the he
probably communicated it to you that I
was interested if and then we had that
meeting and you told me the story was
the meeting before that because I came
to your house okay okay and I remember
that Lucy answered the door right and I
remember I was really nervous and we
weren't sure if it was going to happen
but and we it was not communicated to us
that you were if you were interested but
you weren't in no it wasn't in no and so
I had to go there and kind of pitch you
the character that yeah that's that's
what and Lucy answered the door and from
the time that she went and she like
brought me into the that old dining room
right you had and she called out to you
and you by the time you got there I
realized that you were going to do the
show and I knew you were because because
of how much Lucy
dug it loved the show and I feel like
maybe that has to have had some kind of
oh yeah the fact that your kids were
saying dad you should do oh yeah well
they were well we were all pissing
at the show we loved it but they were
like really enthusiastic about it and
and you know everybody like you know
that you you've all experienced this now
because you're successful and you're on
television for 16 years or whatever it
is and but the idea is that people will
tell you that warn you like
people said to me why are you gonna do
that that cable or whatever it was
you're gonna do that show after you you
know you go to a network show you got to
wait for movies to come along you gotta
wait and if you sit and let people do
that to you you'll never do anything you
know you got to go with your gut feeling
and then you wrote uh you know Great
Character and uh you know and and it was
and we it digested the fact that uh you
know that sweet tea and Dennis were like
almost six foot tall well it was my kids
but you know we worked on we worked on
that you know but does your gut feeling
tell you that show is gonna go 15 this
years but I did and I did and I do know
this about our show that in the first
couple of Seasons that I was on the show
already we were still in the toilet and
it was like and and what it is is it's
sticking to it like they stuck with us
at FX John and everybody and they
promoted it and we kept doing it and
Warren our enthusiasm
you know lifted it up and then once you
we got track cheers
for the first two seasons was in the
toilet nobody saw that show Brandon
tarkov really stuck yeah absolutely and
it's it's about the same right yeah but
that's why you hear John langraf
um who talk all the time about I was
just speaking with about him about this
this weekend he talks about the
streamers and algorithms and making
decisions he's like shows shows like
Sunny would never exist if if we
operated the same way exactly you have
to go with your gut and sometimes your
gut's wrong sometimes you guts right but
it's the only thing you got but sticking
to it has got a lot to do with it even
taxi we went five years and we were
still doing well
and we still had and we had Brooks and
Weinberger and Stan Daniels and Dave
Davis writing for the show all these
people were they were great writers okay
they never let you down
but in the fifth season ABC well I'm I'm
not afraid to say this they just [ __ ]
us up they moved us to every different
night they were using us as trying to
use this as a lead-in or whatever the
[ __ ] they were doing and then they
canceled our show the year that I think
everybody won an Emmy and the and the
show on an Emmy they canceled the show
we were like blindsided I was in New
York gonna do Saturday Night Live For
the First Time as a host you know and I
got the news everybody was
the night of the show like no no no no
no no a week a couple weeks no a week
before and I and I and I said and we we
all got together uh all the cast and
Brooks and whoever was around we went to
we got drunk as we we called everybody
we said what the [ __ ] you're canceling
taxi we were like devastated you know
and we got really pissed drunk uh and uh
I remember uh calling Lauren Michaels
and saying that I want to bring
everybody on the show
and we and I did I did he he he did my
first line I think on the center stage
was uh after the Applause died down
thank you very much they I said Do You
Believe ABC canceled taxi
you know you have one of the the
greatest entrances in the history of
Television yeah that introduced the
world not only the the world to the
character of Louis De Palma but the the
actor Danny DeVito and I think it's
worth because my guess is that the vast
majority of people who are watching this
podcast uh did not see that first
episode of of Taxi and it is and it
might be worth putting in the podcast
man because it is one of the funniest
moments in television history a little
bit of History if you're Louis it was a
voice first like Carl and the doorman he
was a voice and then
they wrote the character a little bit
more because after I got in the show and
then I think it was Dave Davis who just
passed away
uh who was a real integral part of the
post of all of the stuff that Jim did
and and and all all those guys from Mary
Tyler Moore but he was the one that says
hold out
DeVito until and they wrote that joke
like the joke was I pushed everybody
around from the cage now we're Cowtown
to me I was terrifying and then when
they wanted to borrow cab I'd come out
and I'm talking to Joe
Chloe yeah I need a care for the weekend
I'm going to Miami
[Applause]
tomorrow
okay I gotta get tough with you guys
[Music]
we don't let camps out no more oh come
on Louie it's very important what about
16 21. hey hey can I go along I don't
have anything else
I run this garage and no one takes my
camps for Joyrides
all right
give me a minute while I go to the can
thank you very much
but that was at a time when you could
air an episode of television and 30
million million people might watch it
maybe oh bigger 40 50 million people and
your life changes in that immediate
right the next day well one day you're
you're walking around like and then the
show airs and then that Wednesday I
think was on a Tuesday night or Thursday
again yeah Tuesday night anyway the next
day you can't go in you're that's the
same 60 share
mm-hmm something like that I mean 60 of
the people who were watching TV were
watching TV yeah think about that yeah
there's like 50 60 million people that's
amazing how many
different streaming services how many
shows not possible anymore but it was a
it was astounding to
um
you know you you guys experienced it
with uh with sunny because I remember in
the early days
and then all of a sudden when it kicked
in you guys could you couldn't go
anywhere without people knowing you I
can't go to an Irish Pub yeah no there's
no I pretty much go anywhere else
Philly it's maybe a little different you
can't you can't go anywhere the first
time I remember actually really
experiencing that was one of the few
early Seasons maybe we were doing press
for season two or three and we were in
New York and we went out to a Yankees
game with you oh yeah and you know
people started spotting you and a crowd
started to swarm around you it was the
first time that I had that feeling of
like
oh this is a little unnerving like this
is borderline dangerous like Who's In
This Crowd like what do they want it's
yeah it can get a little scary it gets a
little scary when it yeah when uh just
when it gets a little big and packed in
I mean we've had that in Philly a couple
times yeah they start swarming a little
bit Yeah but it wasn't but it wasn't
awesome
Danny out of here you know yeah you get
me in the car and shut the door
there's Paul McCartney like crazy out
there huh but it's amazing about
um the the goatee
yeah well
it's for a movie that I just did with uh
Chris Pine his movie is called poo man
so I I grew uh I grew some uh hair and
uh now my hair is a little shorter but I
had a pony I had a little ponytail
sticking out of the Hat you know like
kind of I I Cha-Cha was a big influence
except for the goatee we've talked about
Cha-Cha a lot I love you know God Rest
assault yeah I just felt like you know
like the the the character of like
um in this the movie was really a lot
Cha-Cha but I but I put a goatee on and
a and a mustache to like uh it looks
cool so that's the goatee and the
mustache the hat is little demons
I mean I'm we had so much fun doing that
uh little demon it's just like off the
charts and it's really weird I mean you
guys did animation but and we've all
done voices and stuff but to go from
Soup To Nuts with a with the little
demon was
I think the first time I heard the pitch
was about four or five years ago yeah
yeah and then every little step to get
to the first script and then to get the
green light and then doing the animation
was like and Jake
Jake and Lucy did it basically did they
did what you guys do you guys Show run
our show but you know that that the
intensity of doing that it's it's so
much work yeah and then you know yeah
I've got the easy job in this uh in this
sunny uh uh show where I just come and
[ __ ] up my lines but easy until we say
hey Danny so we're going to cover you in
baby oil yeah
yeah easy until look yeah yeah
but I can't wait but but little demon
was like
um everybody in it all the we've got all
the you know we had to do the did it
during covid she had to send the kits to
everybody's house and did it online and
all that and it was like just a glorious
experience and the show's doing really
well Show's doing really got like
incredible uh Accolade we need more fans
we need all the sunny fans to watch it
on Hulu it takes time then you once told
me a story going back even we're gonna
go pre-tax see yes uh you told me a
story about one of your first
Off-Broadway gigs where you replaced
Bill Devane William Devane in a play
right yes and then it led to a different
part yes and I think it's an inspiring
story just about sticking with something
but also a little bit of luck and chance
and staying just in the game I was doing
an Off-Broadway play in the summer
the pirandella play three by
pyramidellos three one act plays I had
two small parts in the three plays this
is before any film television before
anything you know it's just like 1968.
you're you're okay
68. I'm I'm born in 44.
okay so
guy guy a guy winds up uh you know
directing this uh uh being being part of
the play
he was like an actor in it and we we ran
this summer calls me up he says I got
this thing I'm going to direct
but there's an uh there's another actor
who's already set to play the part but I
need to read it
and I go okay you know I'll go read it
for the there were backers and there
were other people and they wanted and
and I I it was a great part but a really
irreverent stable boy my guy's like a
pig like a really wonderful part and and
so I go read it
and uh but the part wasn't mine it was
somebody else's it was building like a
reading it was Bill Devane Billy vain
was going to play this part really all
right great perfect for it cut to guy
calls me up says you know Bill just got
the lead in this really big
Off-Broadway show and he's gonna leave
the he's gonna leave the show and uh we
want you to step in and play the part
and it's thrilling right it's like a
it's a huge break huge break plus you
know at that time I think the equity
minimum was 72 dollars a week which was
you know pretty big a lot of money
anyway cut because of the chase we go I
do the part
the actress strike happens in act one of
the actor strikes we struck for like
maybe 79 we were out of work for a month
in the rain picketing blah blah blah
come back to work different director
they put a new director in the guy who's
my friend they kick him out right okay
we go do the show during The Re-Up of
the show the girls playing my love
interests in the play her girlfriend
comes to the play
right and we go have a coffee at the
cookery and her name is Ria right so you
didn't tell me this part of the story
it's all different things so I well I'm
getting to the yeah that's not the good
part yes it's a very good part but I had
to throw that in there because that's
how I met Ria okay so there's all these
like this is a huge thing in your life
so now
we open
uh you know I think it was a Sunday
Sunday night or maybe a Monday night
anyway I live not far I walk to work
every day and I try to get there early
to the play
you know go hang out in my dressing room
screw around I look up their sets being
taken out of the theater I didn't know
they closed they closed the next day so
the reviews were one like preview
foreign
I walk in
right this is the part that you this is
the part you're talking about I walk
into the Lobby now the general manager's
there I said what what's going on it's
well we closed you know nobody called me
or anything you know and I said [ __ ] oh
wow so I got my stuff out of my dressing
room I'm out of a job and he says you
know they're looking for one part
uh in this play this other play that I'm
General Manager on they're auditioning
now up on 72nd Street
right
they were looking for one part they
can't cast
I saw he says we ought to go up there
you'll be I think you'd be right for
this part
I get on a train or with a bus or
whatever and I go up to 72nd Street I go
in and I meet these guys and they're
doing this play call One Flew Over the
Cuckoo's nests that I don't know
anything about man right I walk in I do
there was no hardly any lines it's to do
an improv so I do some physical stuff
just on the stage with me
I get the part
guess who's playing the lead in that
William Devane who bowed out of the
other place that I took that I met Ria
at that he's playing RP McMurphy he's
playing McMurphy I'm playing Martini
unbelievable that's the thing sometimes
like failures you just have to view them
from absolutely perspective and then
they don't look like failures at all
anymore and how much did doing that play
lead to you getting the part of the
movie a lot because well first of all
Hal Ashby saw it because he was going to
direct it first Michael Douglas was a
good friend of mine yeah got to was
going to produce the movie
and then milosh got to see the play you
know amazing you you do this play you do
it just long enough to meet your future
wife and mother of your children right
and then it ends and it feels like a
huge devastating thing but it ends just
in time for you get a chance to audition
for a thing that will lead to a major
breakthrough in a huge film
and which will pave the way towards taxi
and everything right how it worked out
for everybody except build a vein yeah
he wasn't Jack Nicholson no he will Jack
Jack's Jack you can't uh come on Jack
you know you you he was so bright for
that how long had you been an actor at
that point tell everyone your profession
before hairdresser yes and people don't
believe that one I was a hairdresser
well I was first a gardener and then uh
and then a you know a hanging around New
Jersey doing nothing and my sister
forced me
to go to beauty school she had a beauty
parlor you might as well guard in
people's heads yeah what are you going
to do and and I said what do I I don't
you know how am I going to do this she
said well send you to school so in the
Summer she kind of uh prepped me for the
school by you know my aunts and cut you
know little you know she showed me how
to do the curlers and the thing and she
bought me you met Angie you all met
Angie she was like the force behind the
family she was really the either big
mouth you know the smoking a cigarette
you know telling you what to do she says
yeah I went to the school the first day
I dragging my feet I didn't what the
hell am I doing even though I started
learning how to do it in the summer with
my family you know whatever and then I
walked into this place
upstairs and never forget it I opened
the doors
and there were like
30 girls there and maybe three guys
it was like my sister just gave me a
ticket to Heaven I went downstairs and
called her up I went to the phone booth
and call her up I said Angie I owe you
my life everything there was so many
nice looking women up there you know I
mean I so you went all the way through
the program and then you were and then I
worked for her I went to work for her
sweeping floors doing she gave me all
the old ladies I would do all the old
ladies you know she had a big clientele
of like you know and uh and then and
then finally I I graduated into doing
Styles like I do you know a young woman
and I do like yeah I appreciate you
gesturing to me I
couldn't do their hair
but I could do your hair I'd let you do
you know I would do I would do like you
know some Styles I still know how to do
that cut hair really well and I was so I
started getting like
but the styles from the wrong era but oh
yeah page boy puff
a beehive sure oh yeah I could do the
Beehive and all this [ __ ] you know kind
of one thing that that wanted to say
about the old lady thing in the
beginning because she gave me these and
I got really friendly with all these
women from you know all around the you
know they were they were like in their
70s 80s some had like you know no hardly
any hair and you'd have to do the curls
and do the whole thing and then and then
the first thing that happened
like that was really weird
not in the chair oh my God
thank God not in the chairs
she died but she asked her family asked
me to do her hair no for the in the car
oh my God it was the first time that
happened and subsequently I did several
because I my sister kept away from me
I would go to the more I mean come on
this is like this is like gotta be
future Sunny episode
no seriously they're dead they're there
they're done up by the guy the mortician
they're in the box they're in the whole
thing and I would be the last person to
and I would take their hair and I'd you
use the dry uh there was dry setting
lotion yeah like that I had my sister
you know somebody I can't remember where
I got it and you curl your hair set the
hair right let it let it set and take it
out and then cut it and then I mean not
cut it but fluff it up do a little and
then you were like you know what I'll do
something else I think maybe this is the
end of the Rope yeah
but also I'm just catching now that the
morticians don't do the hair what kind
of [ __ ] is that like you do the
whole well no I'm sorry yeah
man
[Music]
uh you guys this show is brought to you
by betterhelp is trying to find gifts
for everyone in your life stressing you
out you know what then stop giving them
gifts and start giving yourself a gift
instead give yourself the gift of better
help online therapy where you can talk
to a licensed professional about what's
ho ho holding you back and really owe it
to yourself to give better help a shot
I'm so glad I did it's easy confidential
and completely online and it really
helped me learn new coping skills and
self-empowerment this year shop for
yourself before anyone else at
betterhelp.com Sunny you know as the
world's largest therapy service better
help us match three million people with
professionally licensed embedded
therapists 100 online plus it's
affordable just fill out a brief
questionnaire to match with a therapist
if things aren't clicking you can easily
switch to a new therapist anytime it
couldn't be simpler oh she's right guys
you know no waiting rooms no traffic no
endless searching for the right
therapist learn more and save 10 percent
off your first month at betterhelp.com
Sunny that's better help
h-e-l-p.com slash sunny
[Music]
hello we are supported by athletic Green
Athletic greens
you mean the makers of the delicious
nutritious green powdered drink known as
ag-1 is that the one you're talking
about that's the one I'm talking about
Oh you mean the one that what do they
say again gives you 75 high quality
vitamins minerals Whole Foods Source
superfoods probiotics and adaptogens
that's exactly what they say and that's
exactly why I took it when I went to
Wales to meet the king of England did
you guys hear about that did I tell you
about that yeah yeah yeah yeah we heard
about that we heard about it yeah you
guys yeah yeah you heard about it okay
well it's just you know yeah I took the
ag1 to make sure my immune system was
ship shaped when I met him that's a
phrase that the English say oh did they
say that yeah do they still say that
listen here's the good news now anyone
royalty or otherwise can get their own
Supply online to make it easy athletic
greens is going to give you a free
one-year supply of immune supporting
vitamin D and five free travel packs
with your first purchase all you have to
do is visit athleticgreens.com Always
Sunny nope nope
that was a trick get it right
athleticgreens.com Sunny just slash
Sunny that that's it slash Sunny just
that again for clarity and accuracy uh
athletic greens.com Sunny to take
ownership over your health and pick up
the ultimate daily nutritional Insurance
Rob met the king Rob met the king or I
met the king of England
[Music]
okay so then okay my sister enterprising
and you sent me to school to become him
she wanted to sell makeup in the beauty
parlor so she sent me to New York to
learn to go to Queen lean
to learn makeup so I learned like from
yeah I swear to God the name of the it's
the name of a product a line okay like
you know L'Oreal Clairol and I went to
this place it was the weirdest it was
low almost like out of like a a Fritz
Lang movie you went into this hotel and
and the lobby is like small and dark and
and then there's steps that went down
into a place that said Queen lean and it
was like it was almost like you'd think
there was going to be a fortune teller
Town yeah yeah it was really interesting
and I met this woman and she said well
you know I teach a makeup class at the
American Academy of dramatic arts every
every Tuesday and Thursday or whatever
granted I I don't think I ever thought
of becoming an actor before no no that's
amazing no well well I did a play in
high school you did I did a no speaking
Tableau I played Saint Francis of Assisi
and in a robe and uh and and uh without
without shoes and socks
and uh it was a tableau I played a saint
but no no real thoughts and I only did
that because I wanted to get a good
grade in my English class or and I
wasn't you know paying attention in that
so I'll do it but I'm gonna style corpse
here one day I'm gonna
and man they feel weird too you ever
feel deadly dead person oh yeah really
weird that's right away did you yeah
have you ever have you ever seen a dead
person up close yeah yeah honestly okay
like once besides I was a kid in I was
an altar boy okay this is a good one
and I used to do that there was a six
o'clock mass 6 30 mass and you'd fight
over it because who the hell wants to
get up at six o'clock and go do the
altar well you wanna so I get to 6 30
Mass one day for my friend who's doing
the six o'clock mass I got there a
little early freezing cold New Jersey
fought maybe four or five old ladies in
the big church to the six o'clock mass
right I go early I go into the one of
the front pews I I sit there and watch
they're finishing the mass all of a
sudden I hear
Hood
and I look over
and there's a dead lady right there
right here like right where you are
looking up at me with her eyes open oh
my God it was scary as [ __ ]
and I go oh
oh
now I don't know what's it like a knife
and a note like what happened she
dropped dead right next to me like with
her and like staring at me looking right
at me
yeah
that was way before I ventured into the
hair business so I it was my first Dead
the first dead body first dead body of
many and it was scary scary as [ __ ] the
guys have talked about the bodies
they've found on the podcast
okay it was not dead body
um so you're doing a couple of classes
right um at the beauty salon slash yeah
yeah and I get I get I can't get the bug
I get like what happened did you get
well the glass or something you get to
well you get you get to get up and uh to
a scene or something like you know you
get you learn them I had to learn a
monologue or something I can't remember
the first thing I learned a lot of
people it's very awkward that's very
awkward but for you from people who are
very interested in getting up and
showing off in front of people
discovering that then I I would imagine
right yeah you hadn't really done plays
no you're discovering in the moment
you're like oh [ __ ] I like it it's
really cool yeah when are you class
clowning were you like do you liked it I
did I did like the attention yeah
I wasn't like a a bookworm who yeah you
know stayed back and you ain't no
Wallflower kid no it was no Wallflower
now I was always uh out front spoken out
front got out okay well listen I know
we've got some clips some Danny clips
that we want to watch that's a point
some maybe some what is it a highlight
but I could stay here I love it here but
I do it oh this is so great
yeah drink yeah you want a drink do I
want to drink how about a hot toddy oh
yeah we'll take a hot toddy but can I
ask you uh because this is ultimately
about the the show It's Always Sunny in
Philadelphia yes you're familiar with
which I am very familiar now when you
started doing the show right you show up
in the first day is set did you feel
like once you got there and you were
doing the show with us did you feel like
you were in good hands did you feel like
you were working with people
comfortable you know immediately and
loved it right right from the start yeah
did you have a moment where you felt
a shift in your
Frank Reynolds like Persona and
performance from like season your first
season to like a few in where you're
like oh I'm gonna try
to sort of settle into this character
slightly different way or did it feel
the same from the from the beginning
yeah just from our perspective it felt
like around the third or fourth season
like you figured something else about
the guy like an even more casual
approach that was even funnier than what
you were already doing that stuff wasn't
funny because it's hilarious that we
just fell in love with and then started
writing two more specifics yeah
no I think I got it got deeper it got
more into like the um see I one of my
favorite things was that uh he I
describe it to you in that scene where I
say I want to be I'm I want to live in
squalor and yeah I used to live like
this and squalor and filth always trying
to get over on people scamming my way
through situations wow I don't care I
want to live like you again Charlie and
so I felt like that that was the
direction that Frank was going as more
and more extreme and I always used to
say to you and uh push the envelope
let's do more outrageous things not only
because I thought that's what the
audience would like and the fans would
like but that I would like that's what
you wanted I feel like I would like I
like to yeah you know the I love when
you throw me out of a window I love when
I lose my memory I love when I get you
know like caught in a you know Porter
body
or a coil in my underwear or slimed or
like and there if you look at the
Milestones of it you can say like you
know when when when this happened of me
and when that happened to me and when
blah blah you know all the way down the
line as a a through line for for Frank's
for Frank's character you do start off
you know basically you've become someone
that you don't like which is this like
buttoned up business guy who you made
lots of money you were very successful
but you're not happy yeah you want to go
back to living like you were when you
were younger yeah and you know so your
journey as a character mirrors maybe a
little bit your journey as an actor on
the show where you know initially you're
like trying to figure out what okay how
do I fit into this like what is this
like how you know what I mean like
what's my role in this I always feel
that like in a in a when you're doing a
movie or you're doing a a part that you
you you know if if it's not written you
always create that backstory for
yourself you find out you know even
beyond the thing what happened to
Martini after Cuckoo's Nest where does
that character go what's the Journey of
the character like Frank I feel like has
so much uh there's so much range to that
character yeah to Frank Reynolds you
know you you you've given me uh you know
uh uh like a canvas that and you feed it
you feed it I mean like why do I get to
become a germaphobic why do I how how
what happens to me how you know and then
how far can we take it why is there hand
sanitizer all over the floor
oh right oh my God what the hell did you
do to yourself
Wanna Be pure I have to say that trying
to pick the best clips of you on the
show Danny is an impossible task
um so don't come at me in the comments
because they're not all here because
there wasn't even trying to talk about
your career I mean like you know you can
talk about twinsies
okay you'll come back again we'll we'll
do some more we'll follow you around
with a mic like tell us about
what are you saying a man and a couch
mellow that's absurd I believe there's a
man in that couch right there there is
no man there's no man say some things
about Frank Reynolds same loud and make
sure that they're horrible horrible
things and then we'll deal with the man
in the couch okay so there is a man in
the couch all right just Reynolds an
[ __ ] who is Frank Reynolds he's the
man in the game
look at the two of them
[Laughter]
here he comes
see this is so long
the thing is you know you read the
script and you don't think you're gonna
you're gonna get naked in front of
everybody okay why we we all know each
other the crew we know the crew but you
don't realize this it's gonna be like 50
background actors back there like
standing around that you don't know and
then the first time you you know that
clip is on the on the yeah she doesn't
talk yeah and you're like
I think we only did one take because I
think we were like we need more than one
we're like we got it oh my God you got
it that was like that was hysterical
that's probably the most referenced one
of the most reference moments of the
show for sure that was so much fun well
we had read an article about people
sewing themselves in the couches and and
then we were thinking like they were
doing it to sort of like smuggle
themselves maybe place I can't remember
why they were doing it but it was a
thing where people have been suing
themselves and we're like oh it'd be
funny to sew yourself I know that is
what it was it was it was people sewing
themselves into car seats car seats to
get smuggled into the country oh yeah
yeah yeah yeah I also remember coming in
over a weekend and having seen one of
those nature videos where where an
animal was being that's right and saying
let's let's figure out a way in which we
can do some kind of version of that I
don't know what it would be and then
these two ideas just about things merged
yes and and and pitching it to you and
not really knowing how you're going to
react I know it would have been a fine
answer like if you were like guys I'm
just gonna I'm gonna do it but I want to
keep it closed on we've been like we get
it that was too good to pick in their
underwear I I I that was too good to
pass out honestly if you say no this
year
[Laughter]
so far to doing something
circumcised on camera oh okay that's a
line he would never no no we would never
do anything like that
oh yeah
you're totally naked because you don't
want to get wet we ball our clothes up
we stick them up someplace High yeah
just waitress the trolleys in love with
and uh I banged her
this is what you're telling the people
on the tour she was a nice piece of ass
it's my body we sleep together we hang
out together once I pooped in the bed I
blamed it on him one time the guys got
some crack it was really crazy
stories I remember
the baby but nobody would buy the baby
because it was white they sort of had a
dirty Brown we were fighting over the
sword and just about when we were about
to hit each other with the sword Social
Services came in we thought we were
killing the baby I don't understand this
talk Charlie broke this musical oh man
it was really funny I played troll on
the musical yeah and it's called the
night man cometh I could sing in my song
if you like oh man you gotta you gotta
pay the troll toll to get into this
boy's hole
I was saying uh Soul he was saying I he
thought I was saying boys whole I wanted
things I like doing most is banging Wars
I uh I go out and bang a lot of [ __ ]
foreign
recap old episodes of the show to the
best of yours so none of that was
scripted
no it was well it was all done we did it
all yeah
I was in Philly we were just like it was
even funny if like his version of a tour
is like just telling stories about him
yeah yeah yeah I like also that they're
like we don't know who this is and he's
like Charlie
Charlie
we sleep together I pooped in the bed
once I blamed him did the long hair of
that season too man like season seven
even my hair yeah yeah well how long do
we have before we start um about a month
and a half month and a half it's going
it's like look at it let it go well yeah
month and a half we'll be good I like
the Giuliani stuff from last season yeah
right no
yes we can't go out like that
look if life pushes you down you gotta
push back if you're dumped a bunch of
lemons you gotta take those lemons and
stuff them down somebody's throat until
they see you up
and if some punk ass kid humiliates you
you gotta do the only thing that's left
to do yeah whoa yes Frank oh wow that
was a great speech man that's the most
coherent thing that's ever come out of
your mouth that was awesome you usually
just ramble that was like a basketball
coach all right so what is it yeah yeah
what
[Music]
well the thing of it is is that uh
there's the lemon stuff right and then
you got Max
and D's bodies okay look at how fat you
are yeah
and that's the thing of it and it's good
you gotta tell us what to do that
doesn't ask you if something was good or
if it wasn't good
I lost my train of thought let's go back
to the bar
oh my God speech and then forgetting
what you were talking about we scored
that which is interesting that's not
something we normally do no sometimes
sometimes sometimes you'll like just for
a little extra mileage that's a lot of
fun
it's a nice spot yeah yeah oh
what's that you're supposed to get boo
booze
sat down God damn it Frank the dogs on
the beach that is genius
what the what is that oh yeah I got
stuck with it oh yeah yeah that's a
syringe be careful they are everywhere
Now give me a piece of ham
dogs
I'm telling you dude they were lurking
before another swarming
got a great idea
that's the best now this was uh oh my
God that was so much fun getting ripped
[ __ ] on so obviously you're not in the
middle of the ocean no no but we were
out
a little bit Yeah the background's green
screen no yes after a certain point yeah
it becomes
yeah because I think we were shooting it
why why is that I shot it in a pool no
no no we shot this on the ocean you did
you were just you had to be anchored
like near a pier you got any cookies or
something yeah yeah
[Music]
uh you know guys I got to tell you I
have become quite the reader these days
what are you doing
are you are you trying to say that
you're better than us
no I just I just wanted to put it out
there you know just wanted to have it
acknowledged yeah so you if you want the
the attention so bad I guess we'll just
we'll give it to you right now hey Glenn
what kind of books are you reading oh
man
tons tons actually yeah I've been
reading books on Audible on my Alexa you
know it's the perfect hands-free
companion for when I'm cooking cleaning
or lounging on the sofa resting my eyes
or reading a bunch that sounds like
listening right because I don't think it
counts as reading if you're just
listening to your books on Alexa let
reading evolve you know
gone are the days of licking your Dirty
Fingers to turn pages now all I have to
do is say Alexa read fear the wolf by
James Patterson and voila
she reads it to me through my Audible
app
yeah I said voila okay but again do you
see she reads it to you so you weren't
reading you're being read too that's
that's listening that's right I'm
reading oh so I'm reading you right now
the book of Glenn maybe you should just
listen to me and go check out the
audible slash Alexa Discovery option
where Alexa customers can simply use
their voice to discover new books or
navigate within an existing listen we'll
let you unpack that one over time
meanwhile Alexa customers can listen to
James Patterson's new power family
football Thriller fear the wolf
just say Alexa read
fear the wolf now available for free on
Alexa starting 12 nine that's December
9th offer only available in the United
States of America
[Music]
buckle up everyone we're here to talk
about cancel culture yay yikes oh
everybody inside the ads we're going to
talk about oh yeah buddy today we're
brought to you by rocket money the
simplest and best way to cancel
subscriptions you don't use anymore or
don't even know you're paying
okay right I mean perhaps you're being
double charged for a service and didn't
even know about it you know that that'd
be pretty bad you know cancel them
cancel them or you could be paying for
services you don't even use most
Americans think they spend around eighty
dollars a month on subscriptions when
the actual total is closer to 200.
Iglesias agree egregious
to cancel a subscription all you have to
do is press cancel and Rocket money
takes care of the rest Boom the money's
back in your pocket and that's the kind
of cancer culture we can all agree on
right that's that's the fun kind get rid
of useless subscriptions with rocket
money now go to
rocketmoney.com Sunny now seriously it
could save you hundreds per year that's
rocketmoney.com Sunny just go ahead and
cancel your unnecessary subscriptions
right now at rocketmoney.com Sunny I'm
gonna do this for real um as am I
because now I'm just leaking oil here
with these apps absolutely yeah I don't
know who I'm paying or what I'm paying
yeah okay yeah you owe me
a hundred thousand dollars I think and
you owe me 150 000 yeah well let's find
out from rocket money and see what they
want let's see what they say because
because they'll cancel it they can
cancel that
you want some I'll have some awesome
popcorn thanks man it's good we're in a
shot watching a movie yeah do you like
the scenes where you get to eat on
camera because I know the fans really
love especially when you're YouTube I
love eating cookies on camera
hello Jesus Christ get out of here Frank
you're an animal
I like to make it in my mouth it tastes
better
do you think maybe you could eat that
sandwich later that's horrible I just
got sent a whole box of peaches real
ones I'm eating like a goddamn
you know you know how everybody like
pizza then spits in a bag I almost fit
in the bag yeah you just take it
now once in a while I do depends on what
we're eating
that that ham
I think we were eating that ham oh man
the ham was great once the dog started
gnawing on it I don't think we wanted to
eat as much but
Frank Frank we are nowhere in relaxing
mode we are now in survival mode will
you stopped being so dramatic
wait a minute
[Applause]
I'm sorry now this was a Wilson yes
thing right from um yeah from uh
Castaway oh is that what the face on the
rum ham was supposed basically it was
kind of a Wilson thing oh that's
interesting this is a uh the debut of
the move
what are you doing I like your top
looking good man
Frank
did you bring in that move or did they
oh yeah that's all that's all that's all
improvised movement and then
you improvised singing go go for it go
for it there was no music being played
yeah no me yeah and then Rob and I went
in post and added the lyrics go go for
it go for it into the song that we put
yeah because you don't want to sing a
song that's recognizable because you
have to pay for it yes yeah but we also
thought it was funny that you were
singing that and we were like well what
if that is what the song is singing yeah
in the twins I did um
I improvised um
tonight is your night bro
you know that bro
yeah it's your night bro because um
they were gonna use
tonight tonight would be you know well I
can't you know from the West Side Story
but they don't want to pay for it oh
nothing so I said
I said tonight is your night bro and
sang it over and over again until people
made me stop
stop oh dearly
a wholesome nut mix
yeah man this is good these snacks are
good go for it go for it deep sharp
beside him in the bar I need it now
let's go oh what the hell's going on
over here
oh my God so this is for the listeners
the um cold open where Frank is trying
to hang himself in the bar
um a real enduring image I think from
the show uh pretty amazing let's start
is he all right Frank are you all right
thank you
to me [ __ ]
he's suggesting that Frank really did
try to commit suicide yeah wow yeah that
is what we're doing that's right not
very good at it
don't commit suicide no no life is too
important in real life it's true we have
a lot of fun failures in the moment as
you've said might turn out to be the
best thing that ever happened to you
right absolutely you got to develop a
thick neck yes for Life For Life
everyone should have a thick neck for
Life yes yes
what is this you're stuck is this your
plan no
how does anything happen Charlie move
past it please
wear your clothes why are you naked and
stuck in a coil just get me out of here
so I just love just as a story thing
saying how does anything happen because
nobody nobody needs to know how he got
him okay
no never would never explain it and the
whole credit sequence is just him there
with a bunch of kids running around
running around I got down the set there
was only one poll in that uh coil oh
yeah and it looked as if any man could
easily just kind of climb out the side I
was stuck in there man yeah and then
everyone was like uh yeah this is fine
this will do right I'm like no just
won't do it all it doesn't look stuck
and we had enough time while they're
setting up because then it just come
down we just rehearsed the scene and I
said are there any poles under the
trucks and there were some poles I'm
like can we when they painted it yeah
can we paint it or cover it in blue tape
which I think is
okay and stuck those two holes in yeah
and it made it more
a little bit more difficult to get out
this is a thing that I've seen people
tattoo on their bodies him in the coil
the rum ham man cheetah oh yeah sure
yeah tattoos
very nice performance very nice I mean
performing welcome
speaking of mortician uh morticians and
mortician makeup the uh my uh Frank's
little Beauties where they put you in
there yeah
what season was this seven
because Max fat yeah
there's so many jokes sometimes right
and then you don't know how it's going
to be until you come out in that more
mortician makeup and you're like it's a
thousand times funnier than we thought
it was everything everything down yeah
I look like holy [ __ ] which one of these
talented uh entertainers who I am not
attracted
[Laughter]
attract any of them none of them and
that's the way it is anyway everybody
put your hands together
goodbye go to your dressing rooms we're
gonna start the show go on it's okay
just
dressing room over there on that side of
the stage I am going to my dressing room
be right back I'm over here I'm over
here just such a you know I swear to God
I look a little bit like um Peter Boyle
and uh oh yeah yeah yeah and uh Young
Frankenstein that's what it is oh
totally holy [ __ ] it must be really like
fun to do the show in some ways because
every time you show up it's like a
different thing like sometimes you're
doing songs sometimes you're dressed in
like a crazy costume sometimes you're
stuck in a coil for an entire episode
does that keep it like fun for you oh
it's not oh and and like I said earlier
I keep saying do more and more of that
that's like what I that's really
I love that [ __ ] man yeah I like you
know like there's so many things that we
do there you've got weird tastes just
like us I like losing my memory I like
that kind of stuff it's um easy easy to
do and who are you
it's not needed to put you in a bunch of
funny costumes and stuff because as
we're about to see it you just talking
is absolutely hilarious uh this is from
the family fight episode
[Applause]
I didn't get a good look at you before
backstage
all right we got some some sparks flying
all right here
[Music]
[Laughter]
show me pig
oh wait this is where it changes he's
like wait I need to change my answer yes
yes
you want to tell me a little bit about
your family Yeah well yeah you know uh
Grant yes I wanna I wanna change my
answer
it's not totally accurate because I've
seen a pig eat a man in fact I've seen
many pigs eating
that's a blood path there's certain
words that are so funny to hear you say
bloodbath is like so I remember I was
talking about that I remember seeing in
the movie Hannibal
that scene where uh the pit those Hogs
like eat that man and it just being so
awful and horrible and I remember that
being in my mind at least the
inspiration for that
Roxy God bless you you were a good [ __ ]
you service me like no other [ __ ]
service
not only my crank but my heart
I'm Gonna Miss You Frank
by the power of the Commonwealth of
Pennsylvania read mental institution
hereby decrees Frank Reynolds to not
have
donkey brains
what that is an official document what
is that your brain on it well it's
written right here in plain English
Frank would you like to clear this up
for everybody well
all the kids in the neighborhood knew I
got sent upstate so they started calling
me Frankie donkey brains and it was very
traumatic oh so I got my mommy to drive
me back up to the Moon my mommy where
they signed this official certificate
exonerating me of all donkey brains I
love that speech because you're like
running out of air at the end yeah
the gang gets analyzed is that what it's
called
um when Frank talks about his experience
in therapy
to a therapist just once
I was a kid
I got into a fight the doctor asked me
question after question
got me so scrambled up
next thing you know
I was Shanghai Upstate to a nitwit
school you know what a network school is
I assume you mean a school for the
mentally disabled
yeah
but nuts in the head bodies too
back then science was real crude it
stuck us all together and my roommate
was a frog kid you ever see a frog kid
frog kid
place was Limitless
there was a God every 10 feet all the
wounds had drains in the floors so they
could hose us down
got my first kiss there
[Music]
Frank
it was terrible
not her
she was an angel
always smiling
that's because she had no lips
but her mouth was still very much in
play
let's talk about the dishes
she died two weeks later
she thought she was a space man with a
plastic bag for a helmet
I unzipped me
It's All Coming Back
it's
like to go to go to that place but say
such ridiculous things that's that is
that's what kills me that's what I love
about it well the whole show is that it
is the beauty of the shows yeah that we
are really and it's absurd but it's it's
like real but I love these real people
getting in digging the hole yeah they
did they dig the hole deeper and deeper
and deeper but they they do it with
commitment and they never wink I think
you never win if you wink you're [ __ ]
no that's what I'm saying we don't win
you're so funny you gotta go
everything about the show is that yeah
it's all about that doing it straight
yeah well we're uh this is uh you and
the gang beats bogs yeah bogs now do you
have any tips for drunk acting how do
you I remember you I remembered uh this
scene oh hat tips yeah tips yeah because
no I don't I mean was a lot of research
I've done a lot of research I have to
research it yeah no I think uh yeah you
gotta you gotta really uh yeah yeah and
you know if you really think about how
drunks talk
um
I mean like there's always it's a little
bit pointed and slow and you understand
that right
wow
it's very good here I love it baby
you're 40 beers back just sit back and
enjoy the show [ __ ] I'm tired of people
telling me what I can't do is that kid
right now
oh that's so cold
[Music]
it's just watching them they're watching
him just enjoying the show
so many bubbles
[Music]
yeah
to you Rob you're just watching I'm just
like I'm just looking at friends that's
you that's that's not even the character
I was laughing the entire time yeah we
might have to use a look from a
different moment yeah we have the
outtakes of the moment from the gang
gives Frank an intervention where
Danny's chugging the beer oh yeah that
was it like six in the morning coming
down where was that
that was in Philly oh yeah remember that
yeah was there was something going on
yeah we did a live like a reporter
camera yeah a live Morning Show
what's in it for me
[Laughter]
don't worry about what's in it for me oh
my gosh
[Laughter]
I can't have you leave without talking
about some of your iconic characters of
which we have seen a lot do you have a
favorite Alter Ego on the show just to
remind you we have oh my God man spider
I like man spiders Man Spider was fun
um we also have manchita yes
you want to do something with this all
right let's do something with this yes
[Music]
there's Ango there's Manchester
is like oh that was big I love man I
love that you in this performance if we
have it where you come you you remember
your name or maybe you come up with your
name he remembers
I think that's a reference to the
dentist system because you were talking
about how you were a mantis that you
feasted after uh and then I guess that's
when it came back to him here
empty there's the trash man
and then I started eating garbage
[Music]
[Applause]
did I get you did I get you Cricket I
get you cricket
oh man
that's another tattoo I've seen a lot of
people getting the trash oh yeah his
arms raised up in the air
um just pretty amazing
we're gonna have so many things we could
talk about some fun we're gonna have
some fun next year yeah uh will you come
back will you talk to us again because
there's I think there's a lot of guys
that I have that we can't
what is Danny like in in person what's
he like in real life he is exactly what
you think he is and hope him to be yeah
wow that's so nice of you yeah yeah you
you've been over here notice he didn't
say what that is though no I know yeah I
think people have an idea in their head
of who they want Danny to be when they
and when they meet him and that's
exactly who he is I've always marveled
I've always marveled at the fact that
you've played such so many Despicable
characters not all your characters but
you've played a lot of Despicable
characters and yet
people love you what is that I'm
attracted to Despicable characters
it's so much more fun yeah yeah and play
the guy who's like you know yeah
no yeah this year this year
we have a chance to like top it that ass
we got something we got a couple things
that we're not going to be able to get
through because we're gonna be laughing
so hard yeah we got some stuff for you
buddy don't worry we got you covered
you're an inspiration
uh I love you to death
I love you guys yeah I love you guys and
I love you too thank you thanks thank
you for having me for bringing us Frank
Reynolds and bringing the world Frank
Reynolds Oh man and uh sharing our nuts
thanks for eating my nuts thanks for
eating my nuts
are you gonna play us out we got a piano
let's do it man God you go you go
plus one yeah yeah
there's a mic there if you wanna all
right man sing dance
[Laughter]
[Music]
I love this one it's a good one
oh my God that's a classic That's a
classic
that's one of my favorites
you can't beat it
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
no no no no no no no no